some days it feels like the only thing
we can agree on is that we can't agree
on anything public discourse is broken
and we feel that everywhere panelist on
TV are screaming at each other we go
online to find community and connection
and we end up leaving feeling angry and
alienated in everyday life
probably because everyone else is
yelling we are so scared to get into an
argument the were willing not to engage
at all contempt has replaced
conversation my mission in life is to
help us disagree productively to find
ways to bring truth to light to bring
new ideas to life I think I hope that
there is a model for structured
disagreement that's kinda mutually
respectful and assumes a genuine desire
to persuade and be persuaded and to
uncover it let me take you back a little
bit so when I was 10 years old I loved
arguing this tantalizing possibility
that you could convince someone of your
point of view just with the power of
your words and perhaps unsurprisingly my
parents and teachers loved this somewhat
less and in much the same way as they
decided that four-year-old Julia might
benefit from gymnastics to burn off some
energy they decided that I might benefit
from joining a debate team that is gonna
go somewhere to argue where they were
not for the uninitiated the premises of
formal debate are really straightforward
there's a big idea on the table that we
support civil disobedience that we favor
free trade and one group of people who
speaks in favor of that idea and one
against my first debate in the cavernous
auditorium of Canberra Girls Grammar
School was
kind of a bundle of all of the worst
mistakes that you see on cable news it
felt easier to me to attack the person
making the argument rather than the
substance of the idea themselves when
that same person challenged my ideas you
felt terrible I felt humiliated and
ashamed and it felt to me like the
sophisticated response to that was to be
as Extreme as possible and despite this
very shaky entry into the world of
debate I loved it I saw the possibility
and over many years worked really hard
at it became really skilled at the
technical craft of debate I went on to
win the world schools debating
championships three times I know it like
you're just finding out that this is a
thing but it wasn't until I started
coaching debaters people persuade us or
really at the top of their game that I
actually got it the way that you reach
people is by finding common ground it's
by separating ideas from identity and
being genuinely open to persuasion
debate is a way to organize
conversations about how the world is
could should be what to put it another
way I would love to offer you my
experience backed evidence tested guide
to talking to your cousin about politics
at your next family dinner reorganizing
the way in which your team debates new
proposals thinking about how we change
our public conversation it's always an
entry point into that debate requires
that we engage with the conflicting idea
directly respectfully face-to-face the
foundation of debate is rebuttal the
idea that you make a claim and I provide
a response and you respond to my
response without rebuttal it's not
debate it's just quantification and I
had originally imagined that the most
successful debaters really excellent
persuaders must be great at going to
extremes they must have some
magical ability to make the polarizing
palatable and it took me a really long
time to figure out that the opposite is
actually true people who disagree the
most productively start by finding
common ground no matter how narrow it is
they identify the thing that we can all
agree on and go from there the right to
an education equality between all people
the importance of safer communities what
they're doing is inviting us into what
psychologists call shared reality and
shared reality is the antidote to
alternative facts the conflict of course
is still there that's why it's a debate
shared reality just gives us a platform
to start to talk about it but the trick
of debate is that you end up doing it
directly face-to-face across the table
and research backs up that that really
matters professor uliana Schroeder at UC
Berkeley and her colleagues have
research that suggests that listening to
someone's voice as they make a
controversial argument is literally
humanizing it makes it easier to engage
with what that person has to say so step
away from the keyboards start conversing
and if we were to expand that notion a
little bit nothing is stopping us from
passing pressing pause on our had a
parade of keynote speeches the sequence
of very polite panel discussions and
replacing some of that with a structured
debate all of our conferences could have
at their centerpiece a debate over the
biggest most controversial ideas in the
field each of our weekly team meetings
could devote 10 minutes to a debate
about a proposal to change the way in
which that team works and as innovative
ideas go this one is both easy and free
you could start tomorrow
and once we're inside this shared
reality debate also requires that we
separate ideas from the identity of the
person discussing them so in formal
debate nothing is a topic unless it is
controversial though we should raise the
voting age outlaw gambling but the
debaters don't choose their sides so
that's why it makes no sense to do what
10 year-old Julia did attacking the
identity of the person making the
argument is irrelevant because they
didn't choose it
you're only winning strategy is to
engage with the best clearest least
personal version of the idea and it
might sound impossible or naive to
imagine that you could ever take that
notion outside the high school
auditorium we spend so much time
dismissing ideas as democrat or
republican rejecting proposals because
they came from headquarters or from a
region that we think is not like ours
but it is possible when I work with
teams trying to come up with the next
big idea or solve a really complex
problem I start by asking them all of
them to submit ideas anonymously so by
way of illustration two years ago I was
working with multiple government
agencies to generate new solutions to
reduce long-term unemployment which is
one of those really wicked sticky well
studied public policy problems so
exactly as I described right at the
beginning potential solutions were
captured from everywhere we aggregated
them each of them was produced on an
identical template at this point they
all looked the same they have no
separate identity and then of course
disgust picked over refined finalized
and at the end of that process more than
20 of those new ideas are presented to
the cabinet ministers responsible for
consideration but more than half of
those the originator of those ideas
with someone who might have a hard time
getting the ear of a policy advisor or
who because of their identity might not
be taken entirely seriously if they did
folks who answered the phones assistants
who manage calendars representatives
from agencies who weren't always trusted
imagine if our news media did the same
thing you can kind of see it now a
weekly cable news segment with a big
policy proposal on the table that
doesn't call it liberal or conservative
or a series of op eds for and against a
big idea they don't tell you where the
writers worked our public conversations
even our private disagreements can be
transformed by debating ideas rather
than discussing identity and then the
thing that debate allows us to do as
human beings is open ourselves really
open ourselves up to the possibility
that we might be wrong the humility of
uncertainty one of the reasons it is so
hard to disagree productively is because
we become attached to our ideas we start
to believe that we earn them and that by
extension they own us but eventually if
you debate long enough you will switch
sides you'll argue for and against the
expansion of the welfare state for and
against compulsory voting and that
exercise flips a kind of cognitive
switch you the suspicions that you hold
about people who espouse beliefs that
you don't have starts to evaporate
because you can imagine yourself
stepping into those shoes and as you're
stepping into those you're embracing the
humility of uncertainty the possibility
of being wrong and it's that exact
humility that makes us better
decision-makers neuroscientists and
psychologists mark Leary at Duke
University and his colleagues have found
the people who are able to practice and
it is a skill what those researchers
call intellectual humility
more capable of evaluating a broad range
of evidence a more objective when they
do so and become less defensive when
confronted with conflicting evidence all
attributes that we want in our bosses
colleagues discussion partners
decision-makers all virtues that we
would like to claim for ourselves and so
as we're embracing that humility of
uncertainty we should be asking each
other all of us a question our debate
moderators our news anchors should be
asking it at our elected representatives
and candidates for office - what is it
that you have changed your mind about
and why what uncertainty are you humble
about and just by the way isn't some
fantasy about how public life and public
conversations could work it has
precedent so in 1969 beloved American
children's television presenter mr.
Rogers sits impaneled before the United
States congressional Subcommittee on
communications chaired by the seemingly
very commonly John Pastore
and Mister Rogers is there to make a
kind of classic debate case a really
bold proposal an increase in federal
funding for public broadcasting and at
the outset committee disciplinarian
Senator pass story is not having it this
is about to end really poorly for mr.
Rogers but patiently very reasonably mr.
Rogers makes the case why good quality
children's broadcasting the kinds of
television programs that talk about the
drama that arises in the most ordinary
of families matters to all of us even
while it costs us he invites us into a
shared reality and on the other side of
that table
senator Pastore listens engages and
opens his mind out loud in public on the
record
senator pastoris says to mr. Rogers you
know I'm supposed to
pretty tough guy and this is the first
time I've had goosebumps in two days and
then later it looks like you just earned
the twenty million dollars we need many
more mr. Rogers people with the
technical skills of debate and
persuasion but on the other side of that
table we need many many many more
senator Pastores and the magic of debate
is that it lets you it empowers you to
be both mr. Rogers and Senator Pastore
simultaneously when I work with those
same teams that we talked about before I
asked them at the outset to pre-commit
to the possibility of being wrong to
explain to me and to each other what it
would take to change their minds and
that's all about the attitude not the
exercise once you start thinking about
what it would take to change your mind
you start to wonder why you are quite so
sure in the first place there is so much
that the practice of debate has to offer
us for how to disagree productively and
we should bring it to our workplaces our
conferences our City Council meetings
and the principles of debate can
transform the way that we talk to one
another
to empower us to stop talking and to
start listening to stop dismissing and
to start persuading to stop shutting
down and to start opening our minds
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]